Today's Anatomy lesson with a whole lot of.
Started off listening to the Sassafras novel,
which was all about the backbone.
And then we made our own edible backbones
using honeycomb cereal and gummy lifesavers.
My kids absolutely love this activity.
As a crunchy mom who never buys food with food dye in it,
they thought this was awesome.
Yes, I did let them try them.
And then we took a little field trip over to our chiropractor
to learn from the expert.
Doctor Mark is a family friend and very passionate about what he does,
so he was so thrilled to talk about this with the kid.
He even sent us home with a life size skeleton who we named Skelly.
Welcome to the family, Skelly.